civil dont notre équipe de reportage se
trouvait à l'intérieur de cet hôtel de
carquif il est un peu plus de 22h30 hier
soir quand deux missile
russe frappe le
bâtiment nos deux journalistes sont dans
les couloirs de l'hôtel au moment de
l'explosion
elles ne sont pas
blessé leur traductrice ukrainienne a
reçu de petits éclats de vitre sur le
visage
dans les couloirs c'est la
panique car le bâtiment est en
feu la plupart des clients de l'hôtel
passent par une fenêtre pour
[Musique]
sortir cette femme s'est réfugé dans le
garage de
l'hôtel cet autre rassure sa
mère maman calme-toi
tout le monde est vivant Vladimir aussi
ça va j'ai juste une petite blessure à
l'oreille 13 blessés ont été évacués
dont deux journalistes turcs cet hôtel
est régulièrement fréquenté par les
médias sur une chaîne télégram un
officier de l'armée russe prétend que
cet établissement hébergeit des
mercenaires les membres de notre équipe
sont bel et bien des
journalistes